[music playing]
NARRATOR: In the rugged
Montana High Country--
This is a scary situation.
NARRATOR: -- Jake's racing one
of the mountain's deadliest
beasts.
Wolves are just
nasty, nasty predators.
They want to kill a dog
just because they're
competition to them.
NARRATOR: The wolf tracks he
spotted are a sign of trouble
for his team of hunting
dogs, who are miles ahead
in the middle of a lion hunt.
I'm just trying to follow
the dog's tracks here.
Everything's pretty chopped up.
The snow is pretty crappy.
Looks like they
came through here.
NARRATOR: The hounds are trained
to track a lion relentlessly,
with a single-minded
focus that leaves them
vulnerable to other threats.
About the last
thing in the world
I need right now is a wolf
getting in with my dogs.
NARRATOR: Jake has
no time to lose.
And with the tracks
at a dead end,
he calls in his backup plan.
All right, the GPS is showing
'em heading for that saddle
just over the ridge here.
It's not gonna be
too easy to get 'em.
NARRATOR: The team
is a half mile
north, on the other side of a
jagged 50-foot limestone cliff.
Picking your way through
these rock piles is dangerous,
but it's definitely the shortest
and fastest route to the dogs.
One slip away from about
a 30-foot fall here.
It's definitely not
the best footing.
[music playing]
Whoo.
Come on.
Hoo-whoop!
Let's go, dogs.
Henry, Clutch, Marlene.
Hoo-whoop!
Come on.
I can just hear Henry just
up here through the trees.
Henry, come here.
Henry, there you are.
Good boy.
[dog barking]
Come on, Henry.
Good boy.
You're a good dog there, Henry.
Clutch, man, come on.
Come here, Clutch.
[dog barking]
Henry.
Good boy.
All right, I've got Clutch
and Henry caught up.
Now I'm just looking
for my pup, Marlene.
Marlene, come on.
Come on, girl.
It's definitely a little
concerning that Marlene's
running around here by herself.
Marlene, come on.
Marlene.
[music playing]
Marlene, come on.
There you are.
Good girl.
All right.
NARRATOR: Jake's
called off his dogs
until the wolf danger passes.
But the lion hunt isn't over.
JAKE: We've just got
to set up camp tonight
before it gets too dark on us.
We'll go ahead and pick up
the chase tomorrow morning.
But, for now, these dogs
need some food and water,
and we all need some rest.
It's been a long
day on the mountain.
Come on, dogs.